- Si vous associez l'opéra
à des airs poussiéreux d'un
autre temps et à des chanteuses
qui ressemblent à la Castafiore,
détrompez-vous.
Des airs nouveaux et un vent de
fraicheur soufflent sur l'opéra.
LUCIE ST-MARTIN, soprano en
résidence à l'Opéra de Montréal
- On a une espèce d'image, oui,
de l'opéra qui a été transmise
dans la culture populaire,
qu'on voit un pedadans les film,
cette image un peu lointaine
puis un peu snob, mais en fait,
c'est vraiment pas ça.
- La Gatinoise de 27 ans est ene
l'opéra de Montréal,
un tremplin important en début
de carrière plalala crème des
chanteurs d'ici. Avant elle,
Marie-Josée Lord, Étienne Dupuis
et Marc Hervieux sont passés par
l'Atelier lyrique.
- Quand on se met ensemble
et qu'on fait des harmoniques,
je trouve qu'il y a unpppèce
de quête de sens, une quête de
beauté.
- Actuellement, elle travaille
sur une création de René-Daniel
Dubois. Chaque année l'opéra
de Montréal préseueueueux à
trois oeuvres nouvelles.
PATRICK CORRIGAN, directeur
artistique, Opéra de Montréal
- Les histoires qu'on veut
garder en mémoire, on les chante
pour les graver sur le coeur.
- À l'université de Montréal, on
vient même de créer la première
chaire consacrée à la recherche
et à la création en opéra.
La professeure et compositrice
Ana Sokoenenenentend bien
prouver que l'opéra tenant total
bien vivant qui aborde des
ANA thématiques bien de son
temps.
ANA SOKOLOVIC, compositrice
titulaire chaire en recherche et
création d'opéra, UdeM
- On peut pas ignorer toutes les
titititions sociales, économiqu,
mouvement metoo, mais pourtant,
vous allez encore aujourd'hui
les opéras, les nouveaux opéras
qui vont devoir sacrifier une
femme qui va devoir mourir parce
qu'elle a montré sa sensualité.
- Elle et ses étudiants vont
collaborer avec l'Opéra de
Montréal pour créer des
spectacles en réalité virtuelle
et augmentée.
- Il y a les préoccupations de
tous ltetetetetes de tous les
temps et ceux qui vont faire
l'opérant depuis 400 ans,
de faire tout ce qu'on connaît,
tout ce dont on dispose ensemble
en synergie pour faire vivre
les émotions fortes.
- Avec ces nouveaux outils,
Montréal est sur une erre
d'alled d d d d d rester une
destination innovante en matière
d'opéra.
PATRICK CORRIGAN, directeur
artistique, opéra de Montréal
- Je suis aussi certain que
le soleil va se lever dans
l'Est demain que l'opéra sera
ici pour des siècles encore. s .
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.